Surprise I'm launching a line of jewelry
Am I wearing any jewelry now, no did I think out this announcement video, no are my arms tired yes
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig if you did not know now you know, your life is different now. That's right
I'm launching a line of jewelry not only inspired by my dog, but potentially for yours, your dog, if you don't have a dog
We could all figure that out. That's right. I got it. Why this where did this come from?
Was like an alien came down
And went to a baseball game or is just trying to prove to everyone that it knows how to do the wave that's right I have
Created in line of jewelry aka a couple pieces of jewelry that are inspired by my dog
Goose, goose is so many things to me. She is loving. She is caring. She's high-maintenance
She's sweet. She's unpredictable
she's
Me as a dog so I used her as my muse and created a couple pieces of jewelry that are available to you right now
take a look
So I have collaborated with OK 1984
Which is the same jewelry company that makes all of Joey Graceffa's jewelry Crystal Wolf is you haven't seen it. It's
beautiful pieces
and
We've been working together for months months and months and months and months months and months and months and then also more months to create
These pieces and I am so excited
About them, and they're finally available to you
So here we go first of all it comes in this packaging which I'll show you close-ups
But its so damn cute. It makes me angry. That's how you know it's good
And then when you open this little box
KaBlam what
There's just grace and goose goodness spewing out of this treasure trove
And I uh it makes me happy and confused
Because happiness is a feeling that's feeling and feelings are things that I don't closely connect to all the time, and ah yeah
So in this 3-piece pack you get a goose necklace a pair of Goose earrings and some bone
Earrings because I have to you know check her ego sometimes. It can't all be about her, and if you didn't catch that
these are
Necklaces and earrings that are renderings of her face, and she has no
f*cking idea
So we've created these three packs in gold silver and rose gold
because
Basic ly that's the
metal that seems to be very popular right now, but
But I was thinking about butts
Let's say hypothetically you don't give a shit about me, or you want to give something to someone who doesn't give a shit about me
I got you covered
Not only are we launching the goose centric line of jewelry products, but I've officially turned into a professional creep
We have these what are these?! Nailed it. We nailed it
these are best fur ends
Necklace and pet charm set that's right
I'm here to not only validate but encourage the crazy pet lover side of you that most people probably don't understand
You know when you're in like elementary school or middle school or even high school when you and your best friend has those best friend
Necklaces that said like be fr ien ds. We've made them for you and your dog. That's right
You can have a best friend necklace and a matching
best friend pet charm that you can put on your dog or cat's
Collar and really just let the world know who your best friend is and also maybe your're a little bit bonkers
But in a fun way
These are only available in gold and there's two types
There's one that says best friends, and then one that says I heart my dog. I heart my owner and
That's my announcement this jewelry is ready to go how much does it cost?
Every single one of these sets costs $20. You get two pairs of earrings and a necklace $20
You get a necklace and a matching charm for your animals $20
It's a great deal in my opinion
So if you want to order any of these Jewelry Sets click the link in the description box below
They are all ready to go
They ship within a few days
So you can have them for the holidays they make great gifts to yourself to others to your pets to your enemies
And I'm excited about this
Emotions! Being happy and excited is tiring
So I hope you guys like them again if you want any of them click the link in the description box below
They're just great for you and for others
I'm excited about them, and hope you guys are too other than that. I don't know